france 3 avec les centres leclerc une
présentent un livre un jour
vous cherchez une idée de cadeau assuré
de faire plaisir à la fois abordable et
séduisant vous l'avez trouvé avec le
coffret de la collection de poche folio
chez gallimard qui reprend les cinq
volumes du petit nicolas
inventer il y à 35 ans déjà par rené
goscinny et jean-jacques sempé 7 en son
genre un véritable classique de notre
époque
les livres eux-mêmes dans cette
réédition cinq volumes sur la couverture
desquels le blanc est très présent et
valorise le dessin de sempé le papier
lui-même est très blanc aussi très lourd
le coffret à son poids et c'est bien
ainsi pour cette chronique à la première
personne
d'une enfance au temps du général de
gaulle très présente encore dans nos
souvenirs et déjà lointaine quand il y
avait partout des crémeries et des
autobus à plate-forme nous évite
connaissance si ce n'est déjà fait avec
nicolas et ses délurée condisciples au
prénom si attentivement choisi alceste
le goinfre eux deux le costaud
geoffroy le gosse de riches agnan le bon
élève il est fou aignan et clotaire et
irénée et joachim et maixent ainsi
qu'avec le redoutable surveillants
baptisé le bouillon parce qu'il dit tout
le temps
regardez moi dans les yeux
france 3 avec le centre leclerc vous a
présenté un livre un jour